[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 échos
votre magazine consacré aux entreprises
et à l'économie locale
au programme ce mois-ci open innovation
communauté french tech à paris saclay
tout de suite le sommaire collaborer
partager mettre en commun pour innover
c'est le principe de l'open innovation
des partenariats entre plusieurs
entreprises pour développer les
activités de chacun exemple sur saint
quentin en yvelines avec le groupe
airbus et la start-up united bonne
biométrique installé sur le plateau de
saclay saint-quentin-en-yvelines rejoint
la communauté french tech les
entreprises les plus innovantes sur le
territoire honteux vrai pour obtenir ce
label
c'est le cas des deux ambassadeurs
french tech de l'agglomération garé en
scène co2 hall tricks et emmanuel écart
président de sky one portal avec eux
nous parlerons de cette association est
de la première soirée durant le skype
business day et ils sont d'ores et déjà
avec nous sur notre plateau gagnant 7
bonsoir donc si aux deux halls tricks
spécialisé dans la vente de produits
cyclisme et vtt et emmanuel icare
bonsoir président de sky one portal
spécialiste des activités en immersion à
travers la réalité virtuelle
alors avec vous on va parler du label
french tech sur saint quentin en
yvelines un saint quentin en yvelines
qui appartient la communauté de paris
saclay mais avant cela nous allons
parler de l'open innovation ce phénomène
économique se développe de plus en plus
qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière cette
expression on parle aussi d'intelligence
économique les réponses avec laurence
l'autre garder
[Musique]
c'est en fait un groupe qui en fait fait
converger l'intelligence et les
connaissances vers un but commun
l'objectif justement c'est de mettre en
commun ses connaissances ses savoir
faire
cette intelligence et la mettre au
service d'un but commun pour créer de la
valeur
[Musique]
contrairement à l'asie nova des
innovations fermé où tout se passa
affaires de l'entreprise dans un
processus maîtrisé avec des experts
identifiés en recherche et développement
est en fait le peu d'innovation
justement l'idée c'est de pouvoir
bénéficier de savoir faire des
expertises à l'extérieur que ça soit au
travers de clients que ce soit au
travers de fournisseurs ce soit au
travers d'autres experts individuel ou
collectivement et donc de bénéficier de
toute cette capacité interne et externe
et de la mettre en mouvement au service
de l'innovation
on parle beaucoup de doper l'innovation
entre des start up et des grands groupes
mais il ya aussi beaucoup d'open
innovation qui peuvent commencer
doucement par de l'intrapreneuriat qui
ont fait une forme de d'innovation
internautes est très puissante
si en tant que entreprise vous souhaitez
travailler avec des grands groupes
l'idée c'est effectivement d'abord de
commencer à bien définir l'objectif
commun à travailler sur le cadre en fait
qui va définir et réagir à votre
collaboration
parce que il est très important que dans
ce cadre chacun s'y retrouve et après il
faut que ce processus soit côte défini
entre la petite entreprise et la grande
entreprise de façon à ce que aussi elles
puissent bénéficier du savoir faire et
des processus de la grande entreprise
sans être étouffée et à ce propos
laurence l'auto consultante en
transformation d'entreprise tiendra une
conférence au ski cubes en janvier 2020
informations retrouvées sur sky
entreprises.fr guerriers en scène
emmanuel car je me tourne vers vous vous
êtes donc dirigeants de start up vous
comment ça se passe l'open innovation
sur saint quentin en yvelines
et bien en fait à titre personnel donc
pour ce qui est loin de portal
effectivement on est on est sollicité
par les grands groupes des ils viennent
essentiellement mais aussi quelques
groupes internationaux qui ont fait la
paix là nous justement bien même on a
une forte visibilité internationale
vis-à-vis de nos activités et on a pu
effectivement travailler sur certains
sujets qui sont clairement une
collaboration sur la r&d en particulier
dans les technos merci et vous garez ans
est alors vous avez fait la une de
l'actualité en septembre l'actualité
économique c'est la collaboration avec
des cats loin oui ok mon avis bon
effectivement si on parle de moi est un
exemple assez concret du besoin qu'on a
la foi intrasèquement les start up de
s'ouvrir aux grands groupes et de
pouvoir partager
on avait plus de doute sur le fait que
le sait grand groupe jusqu'ici avait ses
besoins là on s'en rend compte depuis
plusieurs années notre opération elle
pousse ça un peu jusqu'au bout parce
qu'on l'a on part une opération
capitalistique on s'est associés que
décathlon mais dans la démarche c'est
très intéressant si on parle des camions
ça fait quelques années qu'ils
communiquent ils collaborent et comique
énormément avec des start up pour
l'énergie et le groupe et faire grandir
les startups en parallèle et 6
si je réponds que la casquette comporte
tous les deux avec emmanuel et le reste
le reste de l'équipe parce qu'on est
neuf au sein de la frange tech paris
saclay a essayé de faire grandir ce
mouvement on a besoin de fédérer
l'ensemble des startups du territoire et
créer du lien et des ponts justement et
que les groupes du sky et de l'ensemble
de paris saclay et bien justement on va
parler d'une autre illustration de
l'open innovation à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tv 78 s'est
rendu sur le site d'airbus défense n
space à elancourt le groupe déploie une
stratégie d'open innovation pour kahlo
collaborer avec des entreprises et des
startups objectif innover notamment dans
le secteur de la sécurité c'est le cas
avec la start-up united biométrique se
situer sur le plateau de saclay nous
avons assisté à une réunion sur les
projets regarder ce sont peut-être les
futurs terminaux de la police le fruit
d'un partenariat entre airbus et la
start-up united biometrics créé en 2014
est incubé sur le plateau de saclay
cette entreprise est spécialisée dans la
sécurité des accès numérique avec de la
biométrie notamment la reconnaissance
faciale
voilà donc là on voit le mas sur lequel
je dois donc porter mon visage et donc
je me suis authentifié sur la machine et
on vous avez vu que j'ai dû donc bouger
la tête cette solution a été intégrée
dans les terminaux fabriqués par airbus
le groupe a rencontré cette start up au
salon viva tech avant de l'inviter pour
un pitch de présentation sur le site
on pensait l'intégrer dans des projets
de cybersécurité en fait c'est des gens
qui font des terminaux de communication
pour la police qui ont trouvé la brique
qui leur manquait pour mettre de la
biométrie et sécuriser les futurs
terminaux de demain qui vont être livrés
à la place beauvau airbus possède
plusieurs outils dans sa stratégie
d'open innovation en 2017 des
collaborateurs ont créé lee lab un
espace de créativité
d'abord destiné aux ingénieurs en
interne il s'ouvre ensuite aux
entreprises extérieures alors en interne
l'idée ça a été vraiment de
d'organiser des challenge pour pousser
l'équipe acquérir de nouvelles
compétences dans un mode très
collaboratif et puis dans un atmosphère
stimulante
créé en 1996 le réseau r'bus
développement permet au groupe de tisser
des liens avec des entreprises en 2010
835 partenariats ont été signés
plus de 250 start up ont été accompagnés
pour airbus ces innover pour airbus
développement dans notre rôle
territoriale et sociétal c'est de
pousser à la création d'emplois
réindustrialiser sur la région le flux
annuel est en croissance cette année on
va avoir 160 start up ne valide donc on
pense que d'ici deux à trois ans notre
stock va passer de 250 à 500 des
collaborations ouverte sur l'europe
cette année airbus a noué des liens avec
cette start up allemande et espagnole et
pour recréer ce type de partenariat 51
divine organise la le 4 la 4e édition 1
du sky business day c'est le 21 novembre
prochain
les entreprises du territoire vont
pouvoir se rencontrer nouer des
partenariats et développer leur business
regardez
[Musique]
et on vient de le voir le sky business
day va se conclure avec la soirée french
tech paris saclay et plus
particulièrement
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous avons les
deux ambassadeurs sur notre plateau
qu'est-ce qui sera au programme de cette
soirée est bien là serait en fait ses
rangs un événement festif qui va en
dédié à toutes les entrepreneurs
l'objectif est vraiment de favoriser le
networking travailler un peu les que les
communications entre les grands roues
les start up dans une ambiance festive
donc au niveau programme on va voir
certain nombre d'invités qui vont
intervenir faire des keynotes et
derrière beaucoup d'animations vraiment
sympa dans durant la soirée tous les
domaines seront représentés tous les
secteurs d'activité innovants oui et
j'espère tom numayr général pour ce soit
clair quand même si on est une
association la french tech on n'a pas
d'intérêt économique personnelle
on est des bénévoles on est là pour
faire grandir les startups du territoire
il y en a beaucoup
sur la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et que le
disait très bien meilleur créer du lien
avec les groupes effectivement et créer
du lien entre les startups faire grandir
l'écosystème pour que toutes ces
startups soit dans le confort et le
meilleur environnement possible pour
pouvoir se développer
qu'est ce que c'est la communauté french
tech sur saint quentin en yvelines
comment on pourrait la décrire la
décrire on va dire c'est concrètement un
ensemble de start up qui sont manifestés
qui veulent finalement rejoindre un
mouvement qui est très globale french
tech c'est une marque c'est vraiment
quelque chose qu'on peut pousser qui est
l'esprit c'est un état d'esprit aussi il
ya un certain nombre de lignes sharp
french tech en fait qui permet un peu de
2 pouces et on est plutôt dans la dans
l'innovation au sens large avec une
grosse thématiques
sont tous des tic technologies et usages
vraiment innovante de je dirais de la
technologie d recherche et développement
pour il est important pour vous en tant
que start up en tant que dirigeants de
start up ce label pas parce que je pense
comme le dit emmanuel encore une fois
c'est une marque donc il ya eu tellement
de mouvement je pensais d'ailleurs année
un peu dans tous les sens pour essayer
de fédérer tout faire grandir cette
volonté de faire bouger les choses
maintenant le fait qu'ils aient un socle
une marque une charte à laquelle il faut
adhérer
parce qu'on a des valeurs des critères d
envie ça cadre l'ensemble et nous ça
nous permet de véhiculer cette marque
est aussi de la faire grandir donc non
j'en profite je passe un message on va
chercher aussi des fonds parce qu'on est
une association on a besoin d'organiser
des événements pour pouvoir fait des
restes et start up on veut demain dans
un futur très proche
organiser plusieurs fois par an des
réunions on peut faire intervenir de
nouveau des intervenants de qualité pour
partager sur comment je lève des fonds
comme enjeu stache mon entreprise quand
j'ai de la croissance comment je noue
des partenariats stratégiques avec un
bang au bon avec des bouts de ficelle et
les quelques euros c'est pas facile de
faire tout ça donc voilà c'est structuré
ont lancé un mouvement et on est ravi de
pouvoir être présent ce qu'elle business
des poids porté ce projet alors il ya le
sky disney des les événements ya aussi
l'organisation au niveau des plateformes
vous avez déjà une page linkedin
alors on est sur des plans sur la zone
est immense sur linkedin sur twitter
principalement on a un site internet et
donc l'idée c'est de vous suivre
effectivement là dessus parce qu'on est
vraiment dans une ambiance comme disait
le côté festif c'est le côté freddy est
très accessible
on n'est pas là pour se prendre la tête
on est là pour communiquer donc on passe
par les réseaux sociaux pour ça le plus
simple c'est de nous suivre pour être
tenu au courant des des événements sur
lesquels on pourra le retrouver
linkedin french tech paris saclay oui
linkedin french tech paris saclay et
twitter vide et à terme c'est quoi
l'objectif sur plus long terme du don
moyen et long terme pour le french tech
et la communauté de par la qualité
évidemment l'idée c'est alors là où la
communauté
a été validé entre guillemets
officialisé en avril de cette année on
est vraiment sur cette première année de
lancement qui ont une année je dirai où
on fait des rongeurs ont construit le
socle le socle et en avoir un écosystème
réussir à voir bien cet annuaire entre
guillemets d'entreprise d'acteurs et
faire communiquer entre eux on va
organiser des événements donc j'en
profite aussi pour remercier
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui prend en charge qui nous
est sûre cet événement sur le ska pascal
business day mais on va aussi refaire un
dans chaque agglomération de 31,5 grand
parc et sur le cluster paris saclay
entre la communauté d'agglomération
paris saclay et versailles grand parc
voilà on arrivera au terme de cette
émission un ct la french tech paris
saclay sur tv 60 18 mars y garer en
scène emmanuel i card est revenu sur
notre plateau c'est la fin de ce numéro
merci de nous avoir suivis et à bientôt
sur tv 78
[Musique]